alors à propos d'écriture on a beaucoup
parlé, vous écrivez ceci :
une écriture graphique, le mot pour le mot, le mot véhiculant l'idée non pas
l'idée véhiculant le mot primordial.
Vous écrivez des chansons parce que
simplement des mots
vous amènent à des idées et non pas
l'inverse
-Sous aucun prétexte
je ne veux avoir de réflexe malheureux
voilà un quatrain
qui troue le cul
du champ' du brut
du vamp, du pute
et vous voyez que ce sont les
les mots qui véhiculent l'idée
et non pas l'idée qui véhicule les mots
-Là je suis persuadé, là que
les chanteurs qui sont à ma gauche ne
sont pas d'accord m'enfin bon chacun à
sa manière d'écriture
Vous êtes d'accord ?
-Y a que lui qui peut le dire, c'est ça qui doit énerver des gens
Mais
Ce qu'il fait c'est
Moi je sais que j'aurais jamais chanté si Gainsbourg avait pas existé
J'aurais jamais fait de chansons
-Verlaine a déjà dit de la musique, avant toute chose
-Qu'est-ce qu'il dit le blaireau, là ?
-Mais le blaireau il est à sa table, là-bas, l'autre,
Gainsbourg.
-Non mais c'est idiot ce que vous faîtes là.
On sent qu'entre vous il y a un petit contentieux là
-Non, absolument pas, je connais pas.
Non mais je connais pas, ni les octosyllabes
ni les alexandrins, ni les rimes en "age" ni les rimes en "ère". Je connais pas.
Et ensuite, quand on compose à la guitare ça donne ça.
Et quand on compose au piano et quand on a fait des années de piano bar
Ca fait ça, et comment peut-on faire ça à la guitare ?
-Oui mais ça c'est de l'apparence, et souvent
-Ta gueule.
-C'est du bruit ! Bob Dylan a composé à la guitare
Brassens à la guitare,
-Ca c'est la meilleure école, le piano bar.
-Mais non !